das
hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video ich hab so ein video schon vor
sehr langer zeit mehr hochgeladen okay
das ist das ist jetzt also das was jetzt
gerade herausgekommen ist verwirrt mich
schon sehr hart und jetzt habe ich
gesehen dass meine kumpels apple das
auch in letzter zeit 12 mal hochgeladen
habe und habe mir gedacht ja die website
ist ja echt ganz nice und zwar redet von
der website haut punkt wo es möglich ist
keine pizza zu essen sonst wäre das eine
beste website alles was rede ich
eigentlich ist es möglich bilder
hochzuladen die man im internet gefunden
hat von verschiedenen personen et cetera
und die website bewertet diese personen
dann nach ihrer hotness also wie heißt
diese person ist wie könnte quasi
auswählen zwischen verschiedenen bildern
die ihn schon vorhanden sind das heißt
beispielsweise einfach ihn hier diesen
verrückten wissenschaftler klicken sie
auf das foto dann steht der skating hort
processing und er berechnet jetzt quasi
wie heißt diese person ist und jetzt
steht dort männlich 40 jahre und ok also
das ist quasi die scala hier unten es
geht von über ok bis nach neues über
heute nach stunning und das krasseste es
quasi gott like und das ist schon übel
aber ich glaube hat mittlerweile
verstanden worum es geht das heißt wir
fangen direkt damit dem ersten foto als
erstes foto habe ich land gewillt
irgendwie kriegt weil er nichts mehr von
ihm mit weil jetzt auch nicht mehr so
viel videos macht und so aber erst nein
er ist männlich 24 jahre alt und neu
herzlichen glückwunsch leidet an dieser
stelle du bist auf jeden fall schon
heißer als der 40 jährige
wissenschaftler die mir vorhin hatten
ich kann das aber gar nicht richtig
einschätzen ob jetzt gott leid wirklich
nur übelste topmodel sind und das
normale
menschen wie du und ich halt quasi alle
irgendwie so im ok bis hot bereich sind
ich habe dazu zwar schon mal ein video
gemacht aber das halt so lang her dass
halt lockern jahr her ich klicke einfach
mal wieder auf applaudieren und nehme
jetzt als weißes bild babys beauty
palace processing dass mit halloween ich
habe einfach wirklich gut ist bei google
eingegeben wird
[Musik]
das
was okay also wie wird hier auf 23 jahre
geschätzt ich glaube das kommt sogar ein
etwa hin sie wird von der website als
weiblich eingestuft und ist gott like
also ich will hier überhaupt niemanden
als hässlich bezeichnen oder irgendwie
persönlich attackieren oder angreifen
über wortwahl et cetera aber ich hätte
jetzt nicht gedacht dass wirklich
youtube playlist hier gott like ist also
ich meine vielleicht dass die einfach
nicht mein geschmack aber das ist schon
krass also die herzlichen glückwunsch an
dich an dieser stelle du bist neuer
spitzenreiter in diesem fall in diesem
video hier von mir wollte ich dass ich
es gedacht vielleicht ein hot oder so
aber gott leid ok krass applaudieren
foto als drittes bild nehme ich einfach
mal den lkw felix laden und wir schauen
einfach mal was die website zu ihm sagt
das gesicht von dehner wird in seinem t
shirt erkannt das ist auf jeden fall
super cool
genau da ist es nämlich auch und
definitiv nicht hier oben hier ist
angeblich 31 jahre alt männlich stimmt
aber ein und trennt sie jetzt schon
krass aber okay ich meine das gesicht
wurde halt im t shirt erkannt und er ist
hot ist gut du bist damit derzeit im
mittelfeld also wir haben glaube ich die
erste person war okay leyen warner ist
heute und wie ist dein gott leid gewesen
schon schon krass ich komme gar nicht
drauf klar gerade wir klicken einfach
mal noch drei oder foto applaudieren und
das vierte bild was ich heute ausgewählt
habe ist julien
ich habe einfach mal die ganzen namen
von den youtube an wirklich bei google
eingegeben dann einfach so geschaut
welche bilder so als erstes kam und wo
man das gesicht gut erkannt hat julian
ist okay
review bis laut der website genauso wie
der professor der hielt zu beginn hat
die das gesicht wurde auf jeden fall
richtig erkannt ich hatte nämlich schon
angst dass der deswegen den tattoos
irgendwie auch auf die brust oder auf
den arm setzt oder so 23 jahre alt ich
glaube du es älter ich weiß es nicht
ganz genau ich habe mich nicht so viele
juden persönlich privat kontakt und auch
zuerst 345 x eigentlich immer nur beim
feiern getroffen tatsächlich aber ich
meine ersten bisschen älter als 23
er wird auf jeden fall auf männlich
eigentlich schätzt das gesicht wurde gut
erkannt und er ist okay also ich meine
okay ist immer noch okay es gibt immer
noch schlimmeres tun
mach dir nichts draus ich werde jetzt
einfach mal ein foto von mir aufnehmen
hier mit der kamera beziehungsweise die
bauern haben jetzt unterbrechen und das
dann als auf dem pc packen und jetzt
eine pause machen wie ich dann quasi
dass das nicht also dass sich ein bild
von mir selber malen
also wir sehen uns gleich wieder
ich hab jetzt gerade ein bild von mir
aufgenommen ich blicke jetzt einfach mal
auf applaudieren
das ist hier vorne drin ich hoffe das
passt von der dateigröße weil das doch
relativ groß war letztendlich muss es
indessen mit take away und wir
was
day of my life
die website hat mein gewicht richtig
erkannt sie hat richtig erkannt dass ich
männlich benutzt sie hatten nicht viele
auch richtig vom alter eingeschätzte
idee aber gefühle geweint
es halt immer noch nur fucking website
eigentlich okay ich bin starr das ist
das ist krass ich weiß nicht was dann
genau ist aber laut meinem dictionary
als atemberaubend um wehrpflicht über
über atemberaubend umwerfen
überwältigend seid ihr bescheuert ich
kann das einfach nicht so ganz
nachvollziehen ich hätte jetzt halt so
allerhöchstens wirklich gedacht hat aber
genauso wieder wie scotty palace auch
für halt wie bei mir aber die website
macht da echt alles mögliche irgendwie
alleine in dem video wahlzettel
hochgeladen hat er ein bild von mir
genommen wo ich glaube ich gott like war
sogar im alltag bei real talk like
sollten übel krasse die übelsten
victorias secret models sein und nicht
wie normale menschen wie klicken einfach
mal auf trainer reporter ab laut johann
und ich nehme jetzt einfach mal ein bild
von max was ich mir gerade rausgesucht
habe ist einer meiner besten freunde und
kollegen hier auf youtube max gesicht
wurde richtig erkannt er ist männlich 24
das stimmt glaube ich nicht ganz ich
glaube max ist 19 oder 20
und er wird auch auf dem eis
eingeschätzt weil max hätte ich echt
gedacht da kommen jetzt auch im stunning
oder gott lag irgendwie so aber wir
wissen mittlerweile dass die website
macht was sie will ich verstehe das
nicht so ganz also dass das leihen
die nice bekommen hat und max halt auch
die den sich auch ein bisschen ähnlich
finde ich aber dass dann eben die
biblischen gott like und so das ist
schon sehr krass aber wir machen einfach
ablaufen ich habe nämlich auch ein bild
vorbereitet von tadel ein sorry boss
dadurch hat kein gesicht ich zeig euch
mal ganz kurz was das für ein bild war
was nicht von tage ausgesucht hatte und
zwar weil das dieses hier
da ist auf jeden fall ein gesicht und
vorhanden das weiß halt das aktuellste
was ich irgendwie gefunden habe wie bei
google sind halt überall nur
ältere bilder von tadel also jetzt
keines war wirklich seiner aktuellen
seinen aktuellen stil und seine
aktuellen haare in ihrem start hat ich
glaube ich habe eins gefunden von tadel
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob dann sich
gefunden wird aber er steht process
which may take away ok es sieht gut aus
dass sie gut ausleuchtet hat liz hot
alter von 25 jahren ist meine ich fast
sogar richtig habe keine ahnung wie alt
die meisten youtube also diverse dass
sehr viele eltern sind als ich also ich
würde mal sagen es kommt hin vielleicht
ist adel auch 23 122 irgendwie so um den
dreh das gesicht wurde richtig erkannt
wird sich dass der rahmen kinder die
gleiche farbe hat wie seine haare und er
ist hot an dieser stelle auch herzlichen
glückwunsch an dichte wenn du mal rum
kommen sollte habe ich auf jeden fall
ein kleinen pokal für dich vorbereitet
wir klicken wieder auf drei länder foto
applaudieren und nehmen
[Musik]
ich gehe mit den haar denn hier ist mir
is nice sowie preis
nämlich bahnen von youtube in der tat
das gesicht wurde richtig erkannt er ist
männlich 26 jahre alte ich meine auch
dass das so in etwa hin kommt also ich
glaube ich weiß nicht wie alt er ist
vielleicht 24 25 um den dreh also smi
auch neues mega cool freut mich für dich
ja eigentlich nicht 300 v clone als
nächstes nehmen wir mal die vince sei da
habe ich hier direkt das erste bild
genommen was bei google angezeigt wird
wo er da irgendwie den hier macht und
wieder erst vor ort waren 126 jahre ich
habe keine ahnung ob das hinkommen
ich glaube er ist 22 oder 21 oder so um
den dreh gesicht wurde richtig erkannt
der mund ist so hat ein bisschen halb
abgeschnitten worden aber hat es auf
jeden fall ergebnis womit du schon krass
ab ist als julie and und max und der
komische physiker zu beginn von daher
revier schenke ich dieses taschentuch
ja
bedankt euch bei mir preis
wir nehmen in lisse violet ist eine
amerikanische bloggerin und die hat
soweit und comedy videos gemacht
zugleich aber das hätte ich ehrlich
gesagt auch eingeschätzt also ich nicht
wirklich sagen wenn man darf ja menschen
bewerten sage ich mal schon vom äußeren
vom aussehen und da kann ich wirklich
sagen dass ich sie unfassbar heiß finde
also ja es halt einfach so aber das ist
schon heftig also das war jetzt somit
das einzige bild wo sie wirklich so
front in die cam geschaut hat wo sonst
so ein bisschen rantrum rumba wo sie
jetzt nicht irgendwie so nah an der
kamera tron war dort wie auch vorbilder
wie den installer aber das ist schon
krass also etliche violet wenn du das
siehst von revelations concerning die
hot website
congratulations viel wodka cola trophy
vor
all das was ihr vom video meine damen
und herren wenn euch das ganze gefallen
da würde ich mich über einen fetten like
freuen
schaffen wir 400 millionen heftig geil
dann verschenke ich an euch alle auch
noch mal so ein taschentuch auf meinem
kanal läuft noch immer ein gewinnspiel
wo ihr derzeit eine nintendo 3ds titel
gewinnen könnt also wenn ihr daran
teilnehmen wollt und eventuell gewinner
von diesem trend 3ds xl sein wollt müsst
ihr quasi einfach nur meinen kanal
abonnieren und einen kommentar schreiben
wie ich euch erreichen kann also bei
instagram unter welchem namen über
twitter et cetera pp das sage ich jetzt
einfach noch mal weil das gewinnspiel
halt in zwei tagen endet das heißt zieht
auf jeden fall durch wenn ihr gewinnen
wollt und in zwei tagen wenn das
gewinnspiel von dem nintendo 3ds xl
endet am samstag könnt ihr wiederum eine
woche lang daran teilnehmen und eine
power shot g7 x2 von canon gewinnen das
ist meiner meinung nach die beste kamera
der welt unter anderem halt der liste
weil dort benutzt die aus amerika
benutzen die alle cases benutzt die für
kleine stotz nebenbei allerdings also
einfach mal ein kanal abonnieren
kommentieren wie ich euch erreichen kann
hier findet ihr nämlich ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf hier könnt
ihr einen kanal abonnieren dann neben
dem gewinnspiel teil und es ist
kostenlos und blabla und hier findet die
irgendein video eingeblendet also checkt
ist auf jeden fall mal ab ist locker
auch richtig scheiße
ja